you've got two people and they're
playing a game pattern Chandra they take
turns throwing dice and the first player
to win is the first player to get two
sixes in one here that's how you win the
game now I'm going to let you read and
absorb this yourself I will tell you
right now I mean you've kind of got the
clue because we've been talking about
limiting sum all day
you've kind of got the clue that this is
a question about the limiting son but if
you didn't I want you to work out as you
read through which is the one word
there's a particular key word in here I
want you to think about there's a word
that signals to you this is about the
limiting some not going to tell you what
it is yet I will leave it to you to work
out have a go it's a unfortunately it's
just off here I think it's a it's a
five-mile question one mark two marks to
marks okay so I know you haven't done
probability for a while but the
probability part of this is fairly basic
want you to have a think CF I didn't get
in this question okay let mrs. these and
I know if you think you've got a theory
or if you're hitting a brick wall you're
not sure and then we'll go from there
okay good luck off you go
let's try and unpack this now we're all
heading in different directions I'm just
going to repeat something all of you
that Tyler and I and I'm parent we're
having a conversation about this
question is tricky and in the HSC we
they do this to you all the time this
question is tricky because clearly it's
a probability question they just keep on
saying what's the probability is what's
a probability that but simultaneously
it's a series of the sequence question
it's actually a limiting some question
in disguise we just have to wait to see
where it emerges okay so let me try and
walk you through this let's think about
it step by step
part one just ask us what's the polar e
the Pat wins on his first threat and he
does go first
right this part most people have gotten
what's the probability 1 over 36 now
this is really important
where did 36 come from 6 times 6 right
this is actually 1 over 6 that's the
probability of one of the die dice being
a six multiplied by 1 over 6 which is
the probability of the other dies okay
so that's where we get 1 over 36 from
that's really important you got to know
where these numbers come from not just
what they are
okay now for the second part right and
you have to read the question fairly
carefully I'm sorry I can't put both at
the same time but the probability is now
about this or him winning on his second
throw as well right so when you say all
what do we do with those probabilities
do we multiply or do we add when you see
the word or when you say or when you say
or you add them think about this right
when you say and when you say and I want
the first die to be a six and the other
day to be a six you need this happening
simultaneously the chance is less right
the more difficulties you have the less
likely this is to happen it multiplies
it gets smaller and smaller and smaller
but when you're saying okay winning on
your first time or your second throw
your chances don't decrease your chances
increase that's addition right so
therefore what I'm going to do to work
out the second one of Pat winning on
first or second throw right firstly I've
got this that's going to be the
probability of we on the first throw
okay one on thirty six Tyler parents
everything then I have to add the
probability of him winning on the second
turn now think about this think about
how the game works and I come back to my
clue now but I'm gonna draw it over here
okay in water for Pat to win on his
second throw a few things need to happen
first right think that is if he wins on
his first throw what happens after that
in the game game's over
he's won okay so in order for him to
even get to the second throw on his
first throw he has to not win do you
agree what's the probability of him not
winning it's it's the complement of this
isn't it remember that word complements
the opposite which as you guys just told
me is 35 on 36 so what's happened in the
game so far Pat didn't win but Pat
doesn't get to throw straight away
what's the next thing that happens after
Pat doesn't win on his first throw
yes yeah Chandra has his go now first
right so what's the chance of now
Chandra also not winning because if he
wins the game's over
it isn't at the same it's 35 on 36 right
so this is Pat not winning on first turn
here's Chandra winning sorry not winning
on his first turn but now I'm saying
okay finally Pat has second throw I
wanted to win some what's the
probability it's won on 36 just like the
first time okay so this whatever this is
equal to that will be the chance of him
with you on his first or I actually
should write the words right it's a bit
cheeky or his second go okay now for
part three the single word that I was
trying to draw your attention to but I
didn't tell you what it was is the word
eventually eventually what does that
mean it means we're just gonna keep on
playing this game this game over and
over until some wins right so for that
probability for part three the primary
that Pat eventually wins do you agree
he either wins on his first or second or
his third or fourth or fifth or I just
keep on going until he wins does that
make sense so I need all of these all
the way until eventually we get there so
it's going to be one on 36 that's is
probability of winning the first time
then it's going to be well let's write
this together and tidy that up a bit
35 on 36 squared because we did it twice
times one on 36 what's the probability
of him winning on the third throw hmm
for Pat to get to his third throw
yeah let's think about this right first
pad he has to not win let's call it lose
okay yes to lose then Chandra has to
lose then pad has to lose again that's
his second throat chain dress to lose a
second time and then finally he comes
number 3 right 1 2 3 now he has to win
so look at the probabilities I'm gonna
get with each one right see this 35 on
36 squared that represents this two
losses as it were in a row and then I
have to do it again
do you agree with that so what's the
fraction that's gonna be coming out the
front it's 35 and 36 how many times does
it happen look 35 and 36 and then again
and then again and then again 4 times
and then he finally wins right the one
on 36 is a win the 35 and 36 is no 1:1
we keep going okay but then of course I
don't know if he wins on the third turn
he might keep on going with my play this
game for a while we might be going for
like many many turns right a low chance
of winning and this is where the
limiting some appears do you see I've
got let me where's my color here it is
he is my hey there's 10 won right
his term 2 years term 3 and then on and
on and on okay now to get a limiting sum
we need a what's the other thing that we
need there's only one other thing in the
formula we need the common ratio right
can you read the common ratio off of
this line it's it's what you multiply
each successive term by to get to the
next one now it just so happens the easy
you can see it anywhere along but the
easiest place to see it is between the
first two terms isn't it I cuz look
there's the first term there's a there's
a again the other thing there is ah
do you agree okay let's go ahead and
work it out
over 1 minus R he is a over 1 minus 35
and 36 yes that's very true it is
squared which is actually very important
otherwise would be in some serious
trouble okay
now you're probably gonna need your
calculator for this part because I don't
know my 35 or my 36 times tables so
reach for your calculator and I'd love
it if you could get a fraction for me at
the bottom of here in fact I don't just
want a fraction I also want a decimal
who's got the fraction shimmery yeah go
ahead
36 on 71 can someone go ahead and press
the SD button and give me a fraction as
well I started a decimal zero point can
you give me a few more zero seven
okay great thank you that's right so
what do we got here well for starters we
have an outside that's nice but I'm
always interested in why the answers are
what they are if we round this off to
you know a whole decimal sorry a whole
percentage point this is a 51% chance do
you agree 50.7 is 51 percent roughly
okay why is it 51 percent why what is
the significance of 51 percent just does
this seem like a fair game to you
it's just over past isn't it right does
this seem like a fair game to you
between patent and Chandra they take
turns right it seems to me like Pat has
an ever so slight edge over Chandra why
would that be I mean they do the same
thing to win so obvious he played first
first time now it's still a low chance
of winning it's still it's hard to win
this game but it does have a little bit
of an edge by virtue of going first make
sense